how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things relating to Marvel and
the MCU right now there's a bit of panic
going around because of the coronavirus
and all of the movies and TV shows
productions shutting down some Marvel
production has been impacted shang-chi
and the legend of the tin rings had to
stop their production currently
fortunately for us production only on
the main unit has stopped and production
on the second unit is still going on
so hopefully we won't experience any
theatrical release delays for shang-chi
in the legend of the ten rings however
in some unfortunate news filming and
production for the falcon in the Winter
Soldier series has come to a stop due to
the corona virus as well luckily for us
somebody on the set of Loki said that
production is still under way but the
big question is about black widows May
first
release date has it been postponed well
the bad news is that the AMC theater
chain has reduced its auditorium
capacity to at least 50% in an attempt
to do what they are calling social
distancing not to mention theater
attendance across the world is down
overall and many films have decided to
push their release dates back now the
fortunate news is that the Black Widow
release date has not been postponed
yet the unfortunate news is that it most
likely will be AMC reducing their
theater chains to 50% capacity lasts
until April 30th and as Black Widow has
they may first release date many of you
know you can see it the night before
which is April 30th and due to this they
will most likely move the release date
of Black Widow back and Marvel and other
major movies have already actually done
this New Mutants has been pushed back
Fast and Furious 9 got pushed back to
next year a quiet place part 2 got
pushed back Milan got pushed back and
not to mention all of the major Comic
Cons got cancelled as well CinemaCon got
shut down WonderCon and ace comic-con
got shut down and Emerald City Comic Con
is cancelled as well and other bad news
for Black Widow and its release date is
that other movies that have just been
released are underperforming by a lot
Vin Diesel's comic book movie bloodshot
is underperforming as well as Tom
Holland and Chris Pratt's onward both
were expected to do extremely well at
the box office but unfortunately due to
the corona virus and less people
attending the theaters not to mention
AMC's reduction to 50% capacity they are
unfortunately suffering so although
right now
the Black Widow release date stands at
May 1st unfortunately it is most likely
going to be moved as soon as the release
date moves no doubt we will be instantly
notified sebastian stan is the one who
actually notified everybody of the halt
and production of the falcon in the
Winter Soldier series via Instagram so
if the Black Widow release date gets
pushed back and unfortunately it looks
like it will be we'll be notified
instantly and I'll be sure to let
everybody know as soon as I hear as well
fortunately for us there is still a lot
of Marvel news that is coming out daily
and a lot still happening in the MCU so
we have a lot to keep us occupied until
Black Widow comes out on May 1st or
hopefully not too long after that so be
sure to subscribe to stay up to date on
all the Marvel related news and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers for live updates be
sure to follow me on Twitter and if you
like memes you can follow me on
Instagram as well
everybody be sure to stay safe out there
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof